[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster
i'm constantine kitchen and this is the
show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
and a fascinating guest we have for you
today he is the author of how
innovation works matt ridley welcome to
trigonometry
thanks constant great to be on the show
it is great to have you here
i love the way you've ignored francis
it's fantastic stuff we
we love that did i ignore him yeah you
just said hello constantin oh thank you
because you you said hello to me it
doesn't matter
it
francis that's all that happened there
matt very warm welcome to you
uh so good to have you on the show
you've written an absolutely fantastic
book we're so excited to talk to you
it's called how innovation works so why
don't you just start us off by telling
us
uh how does innovation work what are the
things that you wanted uh to focus on
and write in the book
well the reason i wrote the book was
because i think innovation is the most
important fact about the modern world
it's what gives us all our prosperity
and all the gadgets we use and so on
and yet it's a surprisingly mysterious
process nobody really knows why it
happens to us and not to rabbits or
rocks
or why it happens where and when it does
happen um
and you certainly can't turn it on or
off like a tap
um so i tried to get under the skin of
by telling a ton of stories about
uh innovation trying to distinguish it
from invention first because
i think uh you know we have this view
that the brilliant genius
think dreams up a scheme and then the
world beats a path to his door you know
what's that phrase
make a new mousetrap and the world will
beat a path to it so whereas that's not
the case
uh you've got to do a hell of a lot of
work to turn an idea into something
practical reliable and affordable that
people actually want
um there's a nice story i like telling
at this stage which is in the book
about a beaver and a rabbit looking at
the hoover dam
and the beaver is saying no i didn't
build it but it is based on an idea of
mine
that's that's that is a very very lovely
story matt
and we talk about innovation isn't part
of the problem
that we don't truly understand it and
our education
systems don't really encourage it
well i think it is surprising how much
resistance there is to
innovation in theory we're all in favor
of it if you ask people are you in favor
of innovation they all say yes
and we all buy the new iphone or
whatever but actually if you know what
happens
people think of every reason to throw
obstacles in the way
i have a chapter about resistance to
innovation um
and it's really interesting how you know
even
coffee ran into huge obstacles when it
was first introduced in the 15 and 1600s
um two reasons one because the wine and
beer industry didn't want a competitor
and two because kings didn't like people
gathering in coffee shops talking about
whether kings were doing a good job
uh which they often weren't um so
there's an
enormous amount of resistance but as you
say there's also a complacency about
this that
you know we we sort of take it for
granted that innovation will happen
but then we say oh the only people who
can do it are geniuses
uh who are quite different from you and
me so and they have something called
creativity which other people don't
and i think that's a myth i think if you
look at the great innovators from thomas
edison to jeff bezos they're they're
just people who work a bit harder
try a bit more fail off fail more often
you know things like that
so one of the messages i'm trying to get
across to
young people in particular is we can all
join in we can all do innovation if we
want in fact there's a lot of
consumer-led innovation these days you
know there's a beautiful example in my
book of
something called night scout which is um
a way of monitoring your kids sugar
levels if they're diabetic
on the through the internet and this was
basically invented by a bunch of parents
of diabetic kids
um rather than as it were by a
pharmaceutical company
and you mentioned the the coffee shops
and it kind of brings to mind
the question that i had about it which
is how important
is it for people to be able to gather
together and communicate with each other
share
ideas throw stuff around talk you're
nodding vigorously people won't be able
to see it but you are
uh and it seems like uh you know at the
moment that's certainly become a much
more difficult thing to do do you think
that will have some sort of
impact on our ability to create new
things come up with new ideas and so on
yeah
i think i mean it may we may not measure
it if lockdown only
lasts for a month or two but well it's
already lasted longer than that
um but to the well and the other point
is of course today through the internet
we can share ideas still
so ideas of meeting and mating and
having baby ideas
as we speak um without people having to
run into each other in coffee shops
but there is no doubt that um there is a
uh a huge advantage in people being able
to talk to each other and be able to
consult with each other
one of the themes i try and get across
in the book is that
innovation doesn't come from geniuses in
ivory ties it comes from people who are
socially connected the story that best
exemplifies this is
two people trying to invent an aeroplane
uh in the early
1900s at the same time one's called
samuel langley
he's he's a grandy uh well-connected
sort of astronomer with a huge
government grant
but he says the way i'm going to do it
is i'm going to shut myself away i'm not
going to tell anyone what i'm up to and
i'm eventually going to emerge with the
perfectly designed airplane which is
going to be huge
i'm going to put a pilot in it and
launch it off the top of a houseboat on
the river on the potomac river
this is in december 1903. it went 20
feet
before it crashed okay um whereas 10
days later
on an island off north carolina two
bicycle mechanics from
ohio called orville and wilbur wright
who had
spent years communicating
writing talking to everybody who'd ever
built a glider or who had studied bird
flight or whatever
they just they they you know they
harvested every nugget of information
they could
and then they did a ton of experiments
with gliders before they
ever went near trying a powered plane
they did it right
and samuel langley did it wrong and one
of the things that i found most
interesting in your book
matt was how you were saying that
actually china has become a hub of
innovation
as opposed to the west now why is it
that china
have become so so successful when it
comes to innovating
yeah i i think it's true that china is
not just a smart copier of the west
which you could argue that it was 20 30
years ago
it is now forging ahead of us if you
look at what
chinese consumers do in terms of what
their use of electronics and things like
that
they don't even use credit cards let
alone paper money anymore
um they're way ahead of what we're doing
so some of the stuff that's going on in
china
also in genomics and biotechnology but
also in nuclear and other things
is now path-breaking how did china
become such an
innovative country paradoxically i argue
because it's been quite
free for most of the last 40 years now
that may seem a bit strange because it's
not free it's an
authoritarian communist regime but
that's only politically
economically under the sort of
compromise that deng xiaoping came up
with
um actually entrepreneurs are very free
in china
that is to say if you want to start a
business
invent something um uh or do an
experiment
there's none of the petty officialdom
that would get in your way in this
country
uh you know the newt surveys and all
that sort of stuff that you'd have to do
um before you built your factory uh um
uh
so actually you're free to just do it as
quickly as you can
one thing you can't do of course as an
innovator in china is start a new
political party
um that's uh off the off the grounds now
i think that's coming to an
end i think if you look at what xi is
doing he's crushing the economic freedom
as well as the
political freedom and i think he will
kill the goose that lays the golden eggs
if he goes on down this path
and this happened there's a rather
beautiful parallel with chinese history
which is that there was a period when
china was
by far the most innovative part of the
world around
a thousand years ago it's in the 100s
roughly
uh and it's under the song dynasty and
this is when they invent
you know gunpowder and the compass and
the printing press and paper money and
um uh several other things um
and what was key about the song dynasty
it was the most devolved
empire that china ever had it was the
one with with the most devolution down
to the local level of decision-making
economic decision-making so basically
merchants
were in charge in city states and then
along comes the ming empire and does the
opposite and basically
every mandarin is in charge and
every merchant has to submit um a perm
you know a request for a permit if he
wants to leave his home village
uh or invent something that ain't the
way to do it and
and china descends into poverty and
stagnation as far as innovation is
concerned for several centuries
so i think xi may be recreating the
transition from
song to ming i've left out the mongols
who came between the song and the ming
but you get the point
minor detail minor detail there but uh
it's interesting that one of the things
you you highlight as as
important to innovation is actually
perspiration
uh you talk about how really it's not so
so much the work of a single genius yes
but it's also not just
a process of you know having an idea
you have to be in the space in which you
have ideas which is at work
and in china from nine til nine six days
a week
is that the crucial factor here that
perhaps in the west we're starting to
become a little bit more
concerned with our quality of life let's
say which may be a good thing
but the the more more kind of hungry
countries like china that are
are looking at you know breaking through
at any cost is that really the dividing
factor here
i think what constantine is trying to
say matt is have we become wimps
yeah and idle buggers
[Laughter]
so you will never hear that on another
matt ridley interview
again so this is the this is the beauty
of trigonometry we get the guests to
reveal their true nature
well we're lazy this is the guardian
headline tomorrow matt
matt ridley says british people are idle
buggers
oh no oh god i didn't say british i said
the west and anyways
even worse rowing back fast
um the british were fantastically
hard-working
when they were incredibly innovative in
the victorian times notoriously so
people from other countries would
come here and say so people said the
same thing about californians
50 years ago you know it's unbelievable
how much how many hours they put in etc
um and as you say they say the same
about the chinese today so yeah there
really is a
um a secret source to innovation which
is to put in the elbow grease to put in
the hard work
uh and um and and do the experiments do
the trial and error stuff
um again there's a lovely phrase about
the wright brothers
uh that the guy who took the photograph
of them taking off for the first time
used which was he says they they were
the workingest
boys i ever saw um and then i think you
were allergic
with the word perspiration you're
referring to thomas edison's famous
remark that
invention is one percent inspiration and
99
perspiration although in the book i
point out that he originally said 98
but man doesn't it also need when it
when it comes to
these types of innovations don't you
need time to sit and ruin it
and play and let the mind wander it
can't just be work work work
otherwise you've got no time to let the
mind wander problem solve
pontificate all the rest of it well the
one thing that's certainly true is
there's a lot of serendipity in
innovation that's
say a lot of surprising uh changes of
direction
by innovators they start out trying to
invent one thing and they end up
inventing another teflon kevlar the
post-it note these were all invented by
people who
were looking for something completely
different i mean the post-it notes story
is quite nice at 3m
they're looking for a permanent glue
that works with paper
and they keep coming up with this
temporary glue that doesn't work and
they think what a waste of time and then
this guy called art fry goes off to his
choir practice and he thinks
hang on i could use this to keep my
place in the hymnbook
um and uh the posted and it happened to
be yellow the paper they were using so
post-it notes have been yellow ever
since
um so um uh serendipity is uh
important and there's there's a really
nice recent study
there's a there's a website called
innocentive
where companies or other organizations
can
post problems that are getting in the
way of their development of an
innovation
and say can anyone think of a solution
to this problem and if you do we'll
reward you
and study and this has worked quite well
quite a lot of people have
solved their problems on this sort of in
this sort of open source
way but nearly always it's someone from
completely outside that particular field
of engineering
or whatever it is that does it so it
really helps to have
uh people coming together from different
disciplines my favorite example which
i've used for years
about ideas having sex as i put it is
um the example of
the pill camera which you swallow and it
takes a picture
of your insides uh on the way through i
don't think it's a terribly successful
technology but
you know there you go it was an idea uh
it came about after a conversation over
a garden fence between a
gastroenterologist
and a guided missile designer
fascinating so one thing that i really
wanted to touch with you on
with you matt is the fact that our
society seems to become ever more binary
and that means that we tend to associate
with people who think like ourselves
more and more
whether it be socially culturally or
politically doesn't that therefore mean
that our opportunities to create
diminish as a result of that because we
work best
i think with people who think
differently from ourselves as the
example you've just given
yeah i think that's a really important
point and
you know 20 years ago i was utopian
about the internet this is going to be a
fantastic technology for bringing people
together from all parts of the world so
they see each other's point of view
and have each other's i didn't work out
quite like that
but that said you know you can't think
of
anything more isolating or conformist
than you know a
slightly religious rural community in
19th century new england or whatever so
and so that's why it's cities and
city-states where this stuff has
has happened best um fibonacci is one of
my favorite characters in the book he
goes from
uh 11th 12th century uh pisa to
north africa and comes back with this
idea of counting from one to ten
and um having a number called naught
which turns out to be a really good
innovation it makes mathematics much
better um so uh
it it it it has all you know
we do still have cities where people
meet other people
and we do still have an internet where
you can come across other people
um i saw a tweet by constantine this
morning saying that he likes tw
twitter despite everything um and i'm
the same
you know i do come across stuff on that
that i probably wouldn't if i was just
reading
the times or the telegraph every day do
you see what i mean no i
do i do see what you mean but on the
other hand i suppose what francis is
really getting at is
are we moving down uh because of
political polarization particularly down
the route of
uh companies that only hire people who
think politically a certain way
uh uh and organizations that think you
know
the only high people with a certain
mindset will that
actually preclude us from being more
creative
well it's been true in the past that you
know ibm became
too dominant hired people who wore white
shirts and black ties and short hair
and um uh you know
and therefore missed out on the sort of
uh you know what bill gates achieved um
so again and again
you see the dominant industry the
dominant company in an industry
uh being having an end run round it from
a new entrant
um and that process has got to be
allowed to continue
uh in the corporate world and there is a
real worry in my view in that if you
look at the rate of turnover of
businesses
it's slowing right down actually uh the
the there hasn't been a new entry into
the top 40 companies in europe
for something like 30 years um that's
weird
you know you'd thought in this day and
age you know where's where's the
european amazon or
google or facebook it's just not
happening um
and so um i do think that that the world
is becoming
increasingly uh easy for conformists
and complacent types to
to to raise barriers to entry um
and if that if group think is part of
that it's only going to make the problem
worse
um so yeah we do need to shake things up
every now and then and we need uh
outsiders coming in and shaking up
industries
every now and then you come across quite
a big business that's still quite good
at
innovating and i i asked jeff bezos once
you know
how do you stop amazon becoming
big and bureaucratic and anti-novelty
um and he gave quite a nice example of
one of the management tricks that he
does to
because he's aware of this problem um
which was something called a reverse
veto
where somebody junior in the
organization comes up with a new
idea and he goes to his boss and the
committee sits around and discusses this
idea and
nine of the ten of them think it's a bad
idea
so normally that would rule it out but
as long as one person
champions it then it has to go up to the
next level of management
and that way he at the top will hear
about some very unpopular ideas
within his organization that's the kind
of thing
that i mean it doesn't happen in
government bureaucracies
it doesn't happen in universities much
anymore
it doesn't happen in big companies much
it's the kind of thing
that if i were any good at being a
management guru which i'm not i would
teach
and do you think the problem and we've
touched upon this but i want to explore
this more is you know
that old cliche necessity is the mother
of invention
is the simple fact that right now in the
west although things might change with
kobud
we're simply too comfortable we don't
have that desire that drive to really
change
to really try and shake things up
because our lives are easier than
they've ever been
i know what you mean but i don't i don't
on the whole think that's true because
if necessity was the mother of invention
then zimbabwe would be better at
software
you know there's a huge desperate
necessity for innovation in the really
poor parts of the world
but actually innovation tends to happen
in the richest parts of the world so
california recently
um well china's not the richest part of
the world but it's heading that way
uh you know victorian britain was the
richest place on earth at the time but
it was the most innovative
renaissance italy was way richer than
anywhere else in europe and it was doing
all this innovation in the
1500s um so
in that sense i don't think necessity is
the mother of invention
but i think where you might be on to
something is that
um that bush fire of innovation
doesn't seem to last for terribly long
in any one place you know
italy passes the buck to the netherlands
which passes the buck to britain which
passes the buck to california which
passes the buck to china
and the reason for that may be because
those
hungry immigrant hard-working
workingist kids who start new companies
and
develop new ideas have children
who go off and become you know lecturers
in cultural theory or something
um i'm being a bit rude there but you
you get the point you know the second
generation is often often wants to be an
artist rather than an engineer
you see this problem again and again you
see it in victorian britain you see it
in
california today so so it doesn't last
and uh you know what the question i
wanted to ask you was actually about the
potential downsides of some of the
innovation that we've seen
i mean one of the the huge issues that
we're all
going to become aware of we're not
already that was something that andrew
yang
highlighted which is the impact of
automation on jobs
uh in in the west particularly but
everywhere you know the
the likely disappearance over the next
20 years
of the vast majority of trucking jobs of
uh the you know supermarket assistance
all of that
shopping assistance all of that stuff uh
the closing down as a result of that of
shopping malls
that's likely to happen over the place
leading to very significant societal
impact
is there a is there a danger that some
of the innovations that we we create we
talked about it earlier with the
internet
uh the downsides that we didn't think
about
can be hugely significant and impactful
in the world and actually
moving and so fast and breaking things
isn't always a good thing
well i would say that we worry too much
about the downsides
you know we we've fretted for example
since the 1960s that
any reproductive technology in vitro
fertilization test you babies whatever
would lead to eugenics would lead to
people going off to sperm banks and
getting nobel prize winners sperm
because they didn't want uh you know
because they wanted hyper-intelligent
children designer babies has been a
worry for about 50 years it's never
happened why
because people want their own kids they
don't want clever kids they want kids
like themselves
if they're clever they want clever kids
if they're stupid they want stupid kids
you know i mean seriously
you know people this is what people want
people want want
and people have used test you babies to
have their own
children to cure infertility not to have
special children
to everyone's surprise you know everyone
predicted other ways so that's quite a
that's an example
of us worrying too much about a misuse
of a technology
and as for the automation issue we've
been fretting about that for over 200
years since the luddites
and it's not come anything like true in
the early 1960s there was a huge panic
in america um under the lyndon johnson
administration
because unemployment started to creep up
and they said this is because of
automation
um computers are now going to be used in
factories
this is terrifying this means nobody's
going to have a job what are we going to
have to do we're going to have to give
everybody
more welfare and leisure and work out
how we reorganize society
well unemployment went down again and at
the moment we have higher employment
or rather we did before covet started um
in most western societies than ever it's
true
that each of us has to work a smaller
proportion of our time on the planet in
order to have a good life
so the average person today if they're
in
school and university until their early
twenties and they're retired from their
mid-60s but live till their mid-80s
and they work a 38-hour week they'll
spend less than 10
of their life at work whereas 150 years
ago you'd have to spend
you know 30 percent of your life at work
uh
to achieve the same lifestyle so we have
achieved leisure but we've shared it out
quite
equitably between us and there's a whole
bunch of
new jobs that you know a victorian
wouldn't understand he wouldn't know
what a software engineer was and he
wouldn't know what a flight attendant
was for example so
so innovation creates new jobs as well
as uh destroying them
there are issues of dislocation of
adjustment
um when new technologies come in but i
really don't think
we need to worry about the idea that the
robots are going to take all our jobs
one of the reasons people are more
worried about that at the moment
is because the robots are suddenly
taking upper middle class professional
jobs
um it's fine when they take agricultural
laborers jobs or
um whatever but now they're starting to
replace
lawyers oh my god we can't have that
you finally you mentioned uh the
victorian wouldn't understand it would
be quite funny experiment to go back in
in time and try and explain to a
victorian that you're now a podcaster
i'm not sure they'd have a lot of time
for that quite rightly so actually
but um we were talking uh matt
you know sort of about the china and the
west
i really want to delve into that this do
you believe that what we're seeing
with the slow death of innovation in in
the west
is that is the gradual decline of our
society at the very beginning or do you
think that is hyperbole and
a lot of nonsense well uh as long as
somebody does the innovation we can
still have access to it so if the
chinese invent vaccines and new forms of
nuclear power they'll sell them to us so
you know it's not as if we'll be cut off
completely if we don't do it ourselves
but it does seem to me a pity that for
example if you invent a new medical
diagnostic device
in britain it takes between three and
four years to get it approved
and as a result you don't do that you go
off and invent a computer game instead
because you can get that approved
instantly you don't need
permission this is a point peter thiel
makes that
permissionless innovation uh has in in
digital
has diverted a lot of energy into that
and away from
inventing things that really solve our
problems i mean i think it's really
shocking that that we
are faced with uh you know years to
develop a new vaccine
um we should have been on the case
10 years ago saying there's going to be
a pandemic when it is
let's have a new vaccine development
platform ready to go
that means we can be much faster in in
solving this problem
um why haven't we well there's not much
money in vaccines for pharmaceutical
companies because if they work
they do themselves out of business and
uh you know the world health
organization and other
big bodies like that have sort of said
we'd rather fret about climate change or
obesity we're not interested in
infectious diseases anymore
um i exaggerate but only a bit um uh so
i think that um uh that that
the the there is a real concern that we
are
uh complacent about the need to keep
innovating within our own societies uh
and doing
not nearly enough to encourage it um and
the single thing we
best thing we could do is speed up
decision making by government
bureaucrats
because it's not that government
bureaucrats say no they never said no to
fracking they never said no to
genetically modified organisms
in europe it just took such a long time
to say yes
that everybody gave up and went home
well matt you talk about the vaccine
isn't
isn't that a bit of a contradiction in
the it seems at least at this point that
the vaccines are being developed
predominantly in the west
that we're ahead of everybody else on
that
that's a good point actually good old
oxford
um yeah is is seems to be ahead in
in the vaccine race and this is partly
because
uh the welcome trust and the gates
foundation
have thrown a lot of vaccines in the
last few years
so my point is really they should have
done that ten years before or rather
someone should have done that ten years
before
uh because i think i actually you know
the gates foundations are heroes
actually in this what they did with
insecticide impregnated mosquito nets
which is the technologies that made the
most difference to malaria in the world
what they did with the pneumococcus
vaccine where they designed a clever
scheme to encourage pharmaceutical
companies to develop an unprofitable
vaccine
that saved save three-quarters of a
million lives already
um you know there are some
there is some good stuff happening in
the west you're right
but it it it could have we could have
done this a lot sooner we could have
been a lot faster with it
um if we were as a society more
interested in innovation
and there's something that i wanted to
touch on with you so i can't remember
the exact stat but
essentially uh the china makes over 90
of the antibiotics for the united states
they're made and they're patented in
china
doesn't that fundamentally put the
united states out as a society
at a disastrous weakness doesn't it
surely
well yes and no i mean sure
it's possible for um
uh the you know the chinese to
um decide to cut
america off to punish it for something
cut off its antibiotic supply
but then that's true of every trading
relationship
um you know for years after the war the
uk had a policy of encouraging homegrown
food
in case the u-boats came back well um
you know even if the u-bets did come
back now we don't make any combine
harvesters in britain so we couldn't do
anything about all this homegrown food
that we'd be growing
so and you know and
we don't make many laptops in the uk
pretty well every technology the world
has become integrated and dependent on
each other
and if the chinese are selling
antibiotics to the americans
then the chinese need the americans just
as much as vice versa
and the great lesson of free trade is
that it creates interdependence and it
creates mutual interest
um really well and i think most chinese
business people understand that even if
xi and trump don't
it's an interesting point you make and
actually i remember when i was studying
political science at university
the the stat that people love to talk
about is that there'd never been a war
between two countries which had a
mcdonald's
um an illustration of the importance of
free trade
since actually been i mean you could
arguably say that uh
russia invading eastern ukraine was the
first time that that had that rule had
been broken
but i think france was there mcdonald's
in baghdad
uh i don't know actually uh
good question good question i'm sure
we'll get a researcher on it man just
we'll get back to you on that one uh and
by researcher when we
we mean an a man angrily tweeting us
from his basement
exactly we get plenty of that um
but uh very upset about a lack of
accuracy on that issue but
uh just coming back to the serious point
that francis was making
sure yes the world is interdependent
sure the chinese need us
and we need them but there's a
difference isn't that between needing
money and needing
life-saving medicine number one another
point i would make you on the political
side of things
is that it limits our options so right
now for example we're talking about
the chinese treatment of the uyghurs and
if you are dependent on that country for
90
of your essential medical supplies you
can't
really go around saying well this is
genocide this is
mass murder this is like nazi germany if
that even if that's what you believe and
i'm not saying i know that that's what's
happening but
if that's what you believe it limits
your options doesn't it and politically
the ramifications of this sort of
arrangement are significant yeah but we
didn't have many options
when the soviet union was behaving badly
towards its own people
we had no trading relationship with them
and that didn't give us better leverage
if you see what i mean the fact that
they were exporting nothing to us
i mean it's certainly true but my point
matt sorry to interrupt but my point is
could donald trump go out and call uh
china the evil empire now well i mean
donald trump probably couldn't would but
he probably did that yesterday let's be
fair you probably will do that in the
time between now and the time we release
this interview but
uh could boris johnson i guess is my
question
well i think you're you're putting your
finger on quite an important point which
is that the
uh the the the cozying up to china that
george osborne was pushing
five or six years ago um and
which led to some pretty
unpleasant sort of veiled threats
from chinese interests saying uh if you
want your nuclear power stations to work
then you better not be nasty about us or
whatever
um is a is is an issue
um and i don't suppose britain ever
behaved like that did it i think it
probably did
when it was top nation um uh and and of
course
but the answer is not for britain to
become more self-sufficient it's for
britain to become more prosperous and
stronger
and often you'll do that with trade so
again i i still come back to the point
that
that we do need each other you know that
there is a
mutual interest uh here um
and i think we have to to sort of fasten
our safety belts
and get through the g period and hope to
get to a more
um uh reasonable regime running china
after that
uh because you know china's got huge
problems too i mean it's got an aging
society and
uh a big welfare issue and uh
and and and also it's trade surpluses of
the last
here's the way my friend don boudreau
the economist puts it
so you mean they've sent us um
uh antibiotics and washing machines and
we've sent them pictures of american
presidents
sounds like a good deal to me
and you know they've got that money they
need if they've got our money
they need um that money to be worth
something and it's not worth something
if they destroy us
and what we've seen right now is our
relationship and in fact the world's
relationship
changed fundamentally changed with china
due to covid
and we were talking beforehand about uh
you were doing some research into the
origins of covid
um would you be able to enlighten us
because there's lots of different
uh thoughts as to how the virus was
created did it hop from
pangolin to another animal to back to
pangolin and then
spread in a wet market was it something
that escaped
from a laboratory what are your thoughts
yeah great question francis i wasn't
expecting this video to be monetized in
the first place
um well when it when this first happened
i thought it was very likely that this
was going to be a wildlife market
issue that somewhere in in a market a
bat and a pangolin
had come together in such a way that a
virus recombined between the two and it
then infected people
we now know that is definitely not what
by the way that is what happened with
sars in 2002
with civic cats this did not happen in
this case we know that for pretty well
certain now
because the samples that were taken from
that wet market were all negative they
never found a positive sample
and moreover the people in the market
who caught it
caught a very well adapted to human
beings form of the virus
so that the market was a super spreader
event not a zoonotic event to use the
technical terminology this wasn't where
it jumped we now know that
pretty well said and the other weird
thing is
that in sars or mers or any of these
other things we quite soon identify
the source of the virus the animal that
has this virus in it
in this case we have still not done so
now you may have heard of this bat
sample ratg13
but that doesn't have the virus that
infects us that is a very similar virus
but it's a
it's it's not nearly similar enough it's
40 years divergent if you're if you use
normal evolutionary time scales um
and in particular its spike protein
which is the
bit that it uses to get inside the cells
is very different is really not close
enough at all
um now the pangolins have another virus
that's
less close than the bat one but its
spike protein is
more close than the back one so neither
of these viruses can be the one that
that somebody caught in october november
last year in wuhan
okay they he somebody there caught a
different
virus now was it caught from a village
in yunnan
where these two viruses had come
together at some point and recombined
possibly or was it caught from a lab
where experiments were being done to
combine the spike protein
of one virus with the backbone of
another virus
those were exactly the experiments that
the wuhan institute of virology was
doing
with coronaviruses they were making
so-called chimeric
pseudoviruses with the the the backbone
of one virus
and the spike protein of another now
they won't say
um uh whether they were
experimenting with this particular virus
with the bat
version in fact they say the bat sample
they found it in their files and isn't
already disintegrated so we can't go
back and look at it again
which is a bit weird um but actually we
now know
that actually when they found it in
their files they didn't admit that it's
actually something they'd called by a
different name for 991
back in 2012 when they isolated it from
a 2013 sorry from a bunch of miners
who died going into a copper mine in
southern yunnan
three of them died and they died with
pneumonia and had a and tested positive
for an unknown coronavirus
um so it's looking very like someone is
covering up something about work that
was done on this virus over the last
five or six years
um either because they
fear that it might be the source or they
know that it might be the source
now that's the wrong way to go about it
because it's still very likely that it's
not the source that it wasn't a lab leak
and the way to prove that is to come out
and give us absolute
open transparency about every experiment
that was done in that institute
and that way and you know make zhang xi
jing li
and uh tian jun juan these people who
are working on bat virus make them
available for interviews
now if if china would do that then we
could rule
out the lab leak hypothesis but at the
moment we can't if
far from becoming less plausible it is
becoming more plausible the more we find
out
and you have just made every weed smoker
on the internet incredibly happy matt i
want you to know that
they're sitting at their computers going
i knew it i knew it
well i know that is the danger and of
course you know
there is a fate worse than death on the
internet and that is to
adopt a position that is also adopted by
donald trump
well i was going to say you would have
upset a few david ike fans
uh earlier in the interview but now now
you've made some of them happy so
it comes out but
uh but just sticking with that i mean
obviously
as you talked earlier about the kind of
regime that china has
xi jinping wouldn't be the sort of
person that would allow that sort of
information to be
properly ventilated outside of outside
of china if there was
a risk that china had been responsible
or this laboratory had been responsible
um and i guess it comes back to what we
were talking about earlier which is
you know the the negative sides of
innovation i mean why
actually for most people an interesting
question might be
why would a laboratory be doing these
sort of experiments what is
are they trying to develop biological
weapons or are there legitimate reasons
to try and
no there are legitimate reasons and and
they were quite open about this a few
years ago because there's two labs
in a sort of rival friendly rivalry
doing this one is in north carolina
uh chapel hill and the other is in wuhan
these are the two leading
chimera viruses labs in the world
um and they published a joint paper in
2015
in which they say you know what maybe
these experiments
are a little too dangerous because we
now realize that
because what what we're trying to do is
create a virus in the lab that has the
characteristics of
sars or something like it but can
definitely infect human cells not just
bat cells
so that we can study it so that we can
then develop therapies and vaccines to
defeat it
but we realize that in the process we
are creating viruses that are more
dangerous to human beings
so they said that and they said you know
some of these experiments are uh you
know ones that we perhaps shouldn't be
doing
after that the us government put a
moratorium on such experiments
but it only lasted for a couple of years
it lifted it again
um and the chinese government didn't put
a moratorium on on these experiments
so the motive was definitely good let's
study the heck out of coronaviruses so
that when a pandemic does start
we know what to do about them but it
didn't work
in the sense that it didn't put us in a
position to have a quick vaccine
or therapy ready um and it may indeed
have made the made the pandemic more
likely
and what responsibility do you think
china have to take for this pandemic
do they have any responsibility did they
do enough or were they being
uh circumspect with the truth
well um obviously
you can't be responsible for a natural
accident that happens within your own
borders but when i thought it was a
wildlife wet market
issue as it probably was i thought they
had considerable responsibility
because after sars which did happen in a
wildlife market
um there were plenty of warnings
you know there's a hong kong scientist
who used the word time bomb ticking time
bomb about wildlife markets
um and you would think and and short and
after sars they did
shut down a lot of these markets they've
then reopened them progressively in the
last few years
and indeed
xi jinping has been particularly
espousing traditional chinese medicine
and the only reason you buy
pangolins it's not because they're good
to eat but because you think they're
they're a medical uh help to you know
for health reasons not for
nutritious reasons um so
in that sense the chinese authorities do
have culpability for not doing more to
control the wildlife trade
and you know let's face it there's
another reason for that which is that we
don't want pangolins to go extinct and
chinese demand is what is driving
pangolin smuggling from malaysia
but i have to now admit that argument
has got weaker
now that we know the wildlife market
wasn't responsible in this case
so attention then turns to the question
of the
um the lab and was the lab doing
something for which china
should be held accountable and the
answer there is we simply don't yet know
but we need to know more and how how are
we ever going to get
that information do you think
i don't know um i um
i have such faith in human nature that
i'm pretty sure
there are scientists within the labs
who will want to get the information out
and will eventually find a way
but uh the longer this goes on and the
more
tracks are covered i mean the only
reason we know about these copper miners
who got ill in 2012
uh in yernan is because um
while a lot of stuff was taken offline
over the last few months
a master's thesis that discussed this
case was not they missed it
so you know that's quite a nice example
of how
hard it is for them to
to censor all this and shut all this
down and they have got some good reasons
for censoring it which is that nutters
in the west are going to make absolute
hay with anything that comes out
um you can include me in that phrase if
if you wish
so you self-identify as a nutter do you
don't you absolutely
[Laughter]
but matt let me ask you this because i
think just
for people who who don't have the
scientific understanding of what you're
talking about
as i don't as francis doesn't um
if you're saying it's highly unlikely
now that this happened at a web market
other than some kind of problem that
occurred in a lab is there another way
that this could have happened
yes um yes the other hypothesis which is
still very plausible is that somewhere
in yunnan
far south of china which is where these
viruses seem to
exist in bats or similar viruses seem to
exist in bats
somewhere there a a chap going into a
cave to dig back guano for use on his
fields
um picked up two different coronaviruses
um from uh probably from one
species or possibly from two species of
um
horseshoe bat and inside his own body
those two recombined to produce a brand
new virus
and we know this can happen and this
coronaviruses are particularly good at
this natural recombination
um and he then gave it to a couple of
people in his village
who gave it to a couple of people but it
never really took off
but over a number of months it became
better and better at infecting human
beings
until the point where it actually
somebody traveled to wuhan
and started coughing in a restaurant or
on a crowded train or something like
that and then it exploded
uh so um that is
you know as it were just as plausible a
hypothesis
and those are the two hypotheses that i
think we need to um
to put up against each other and you
know in that scenario the chinese have
got nothing to
to blame themselves with it they
couldn't have foreseen it and they and
they
there was nothing they could have done
and matt
donald trump has been famously uh very
very critical of the w.h.o
um where do you stand on this do you
think uh his criticisms are justified
and uh or do you think they've been
unfairly blamed for their
handling of this particular crisis i
think the who has been
very poorly indeed in this crisis their
refusal to
um talk to taiwan even when the
taiwanese
scientists were saying there is human to
human transmission
um there they they
as late as the middle of january the wha
put out a statement saying
this virus does not transmit from humans
to humans
that's naughty i mean by then there was
plenty of good evidence they were
ignoring it they were taking chinese
assurances at face value
and also in a more general way i think
the world health organization has not
been doing its day job which is to keep
us safe from pandemic infectious threats
the wh was spending a huge amount of
energy trying to suppress
e-cigarettes and vaping over the last
few years
five years ago it put out a statement
saying the greatest threat to human
health
in the 21st century is climate change
this doesn't suggest an organization
that was focusing on its day job
and in the ebola outbreak of 2014-15
the who eventually produced a hugely
self-critical
report saying that it had
for political reasons so as not to
offend people in
um guinea sierra leone and liberia
it had um long after it shouldn't have
done
it had reassured people that the
situation was under control
when medicines are frontiers and other
charities were saying it's not under
control
um so i i think the world health
organization
is a an organization that is uh
corrupt with a small sea not fit for
uh mission and uh has performed badly
whether the right thing to do is to cut
off its funds uh i don't know
um but as one of the largest funders the
uk has some responsibility i think
to push for some pretty serious reforms
here
that is really stinging criticism there
i would say
of the of the organization do we know
why uh the who behaved in this way with
this virus
is it a political issue is it an issue
of incompetence
is it an issue of something else
i think a lot of these big international
organizations end up
being very bureaucratic very political
um
uh it's in the nature of the beast
uh the particular appointment of
dr ted ross from ethiopia as a
as director general of the who in
competition with
a brit called david nabarro
a few years ago i think was a mistake
um he was the former ethiopian
foreign minister and health minister um
and as such he had been very very close
to china
and ethiopia is china's
sort of favorite country in africa so
there is a very close relationship there
and you know just for example the
business that taiwan is not allowed to
be part
of the wha or even attend its meetings
that is something
china has only recently begun to insist
on and the who has just gone along with
it it hasn't protested
before that the previous chinese regimes
were being more reasonable about taiwan
so essentially they're quite a v they're
a very weak organization with no real
power
and instead of standing up to china and
being honest they count out to them and
they saw well they helped us get to
where we are
well we'll we'll have to see what
happens with their investigation into
the origin of the virus which they
recently announced
but it has um uh also announced
that it won't be visiting the wuhan
institute of virology which does seem to
be a pity
i mean that's uh that that's like not
going
to to the potential murder scene isn't
it if you're investigating a murder
wouldn't that be a good analogy
i think so yeah right
okay i'm slightly lost for words here so
why wouldn't they do that um
i don't know you'll have to ask them
yeah i'm sure
ted ross is coming we'll be very happy
to come and trigger knowledge we'll find
out
but but then that begs the question
what's the point of having this
investigation
well um they will presumably talk to
lots of people in the chinese
academy of sciences and in the centers
for disease control
which uh and in the wuhan government as
well as the
national government and
they will hope to get direct answers
the way you've described that gives me
no confidence whatsoever i have to say
uh and you're nodding again people won't
be able to see it but
uh okay guys well i i don't really know
where to go from here matt
um it doesn't sound like we're really
going to get i got you into terrible
trouble and myself
no problem yourself uh we're going to be
fine
i mean we've already been tried to been
cancelled about eight times we've lost
the studio three times
i i'm more lost for words because uh i
mean
that does not sound like a good way to
be dealing with this situation man
and and it sounds to me we joke about it
we laugh about her but
from what you're telling us we've had a
serious problem
which may have been man-made and the
investigation
into this problem is not going to look
at what may well have been the source of
the problem
that and rely solely on evidence from
people who
who who have a political reason not to
give straight answers
is that an echo summary yeah i think it
is and i would repeat the point that
if it's not man-made if it didn't come
out of the lab
then the the only way you're going to
persuade us
that that's the case is by being
completely open about what was going on
in the lab
and that's not what we're getting at the
moment
well ladies and gentlemen there we go i
don't know where to go from here this is
crazy
you you're basically saying to i i don't
francis
help me out here man uh what he's saying
is there's no point in uh the report
uh the the who is at the behest of china
and uh we're [ __ ] anyway great
fantastic stuff uh all right well uh
matt the last question we
always ask is what's the one thing we're
not talking about that we should be but
that sounds to me like what we should be
talking about isn't it
yeah that's quite a good answer but the
the
the the other thing that i think is a
terribly important thing and i'm a
biologist really originally
and i'm a keen naturalist we don't talk
nearly enough about invasive species
i just seen a grey squirrel go past my
window this is a species that's wiping
out the red squirrel
um there's all sorts of uh wherever you
go in the world you know ash die back
killing
things this is the big conservation
issue and
we we neglect it in favor of climate
change or
other issues or air pollution or
something but i i think invasive species
are a terribly important issue
but that's for another day yeah i'm not
sure that's going to be what we lead
with in publishing this episode
given some of the stuff we just talked
about
but listen uh thank you so much for
talking to us the book is absolutely
fantastic and beautifully written as
well
it's very easy to read lots of
interesting stories to illustrate the
points that you're making
how innovation works i i recommend
everybody
gets it uh if you
i i this is the first time i'm lost for
words in doing trigonometry
i don't know what to say get the book
but also
wear a mask and should we wear masks
even let's talk about that before we go
oh yeah um well um
i'm not sure uh i mean it seems crazy to
be
making masks compulsory at this stage
you know if
we should have done so back in march if
if we were serious about it
but i do i i i i'm not an anti-mask
fanatic
um because i do think they to some
extent a they signal that you're trying
and b they do make some sort of
difference i personally can't stand
the ordinary masks because they fog up
my spectacles
so i've gone and got one of these uh you
know what are called visor things you
know like you're a
knight in shining armor except it's made
of plastic and um
you can see through them and they're
great i mean i i find that much the
easiest way so when i was
at an airport recently i was wearing
that instead and you can even
you can even eat under them you have to
sort of do this but
all right well there we go buy the book
where advisor and
uh don't eat bats or i i don't
maybe we'll end on that uh matt ridley
thank you so much for coming on the show
it's been a pleasure
uh and uh yeah we're all gonna look into
the wa jo now
absolutely good work thank you very much
matt and if you
want uh to uh follow us please remember
that
all our episodes uh come out and
live streams come out six nights a week
and they are always
7 p.m uk time that's 7 p.m uk time
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word